PUCK 4th LINE SO
CONFIDENT  SHOT HIGH
AND OUT OF PLAY.
>>
KANEER BACK WHEN STAYS
THE PUCK AND LANKINEN
FOLLOWS HIM EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY.
POINT OF EMPHASIS
FOR DEREK KING.
NT LESS,  THE HAWKS    ,
ANOTHER ACQUISITION
FOR THIS YEAR.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT
>> THERE IS AMADIO WHIP
SHIFTINESS IN HIS
GAME.
AFTER VEGAS GAINS
ENTRY, A BIT OF A
BROKEN PLAY.
AS
INAUDIBLE ] IF THEY
HAVE TOO.
>> 6
WORK CYCLING
FAIRY, HE
RECORD FOR THE SABRES
WHO WE'LL SEE ON
FRIDAY NIGHTIN
FOR THE GOLDEN
KNIGHTS, SAM LAFFERTY
TRIES TO GET OAND HEHE'
HE PINCHESMAYBE TH
A MAX PACIORETTY,
GREAT PLAY.
PACIORETTY MIS JONES PL
LAFFERTY, JONES DIVE,
SHOT BY LAFFERTY, OUT
OF PLAY.
HOW ABOUT SETHINLY.
WA ANDOWN TO A TIED
GAMEDEBRINCAT WITH LESS
THAN 15 SECONDS.
>> NOW THE
READY, OUTAS HE'S BACKI
TRAJECTION ON THIS
ONE.
HE JUST MISSED, UP
AND OVER.
JACK
IN AND TRIES TO GO
GLOVE SIDE.
GO
BACK TO THE FOREHAND.
LANKINEN COMES IN
BIG.
G.
>> HE
UNFORTUNATELY,
THOMPSON ABLE TO GET
ON IT.
QUICK SHOT OFFI CAN ONL
QUICK SNAPSHOT OFF
AND THOOK EASY.
AGAIN, TRYING TO GO
GLOVE SIDE ON